you know how many people are in the USA
3 billion
yes do you know who fought in the Civil
War
who fought in the Civil War yeah
he loves moms you gotta hit him up
and showing his nipples
yes do you know how many states there
are
as a star for each state so 51.
yes close enough
around how many if you had to guess
[Music]
200 trillion some something like that
how many states make up the United
States
around how many 13.
yes
do you know how many stars are on the
U.S flag 50. you know what the Stars
stand for no
take a guess
please don't say the number of states
or you just said the number of laws I I
have no I was right yes you just guessed
yeah around how many people would you
say live on earth
on Earth yeah
8 million
million or billion eight million there's
more than that yes I was just gonna say
that there's literally more than that in
like a 10 mile radius of you right now
what is it like it's like six it's six
billion right parties is this health
group up to seven billion but yeah
that's crazy positive to be honest
um do you know when the War of 1812 was
it a while ago like recently like that's
crazy that's World War II
yeah give me a year the war of 1812. oh
you heard of that one it was like that's
like the 1980s
very
good very good little buddy very good am
I wrong what country we gained our
independence from
France
yes how many people on earth
I have no idea around how many if you
have to guess
um
a couple trillion
yes how many states make up the USA
there was a sticker on the skateboard
what's up with that is that a brand or
something I don't know trillion
yes how many states make up the USA
55. do you know what the letter O on the
periodic table stands for
bruh
nah take a guess what do you think it
stands for
octopus
yes he doesn't even know what the
periodic table is I wasn't even good at
school and I know these I feel like this
makes me feel like [__] I went to
school in the Dark Ages and I remember
what it is what's the third month of
each year
what do you think she's gonna say took a
guess if you guess it I'll give you a
hundred dollars Tuesday August third
month of each year is
February huh yes so what year is the war
of 18.
[Music]
I must say
18 25 Maybe
yes do it three times three times three
is where do I get me one of these
stylish old school outfit though those
things came out those mesh shirts came
out in the 80s and they had a huge run
you wore these guys or girls uh guys but
not
um guys in skirts and heels guys like
muscle guys with great Tans they wore
like a neon yellow mesh shirt to make
their tan pop and a lot of muscles so it
actually looked decent it's like a guido
thing yeah
interesting
can't stop looking at his three times
three is six six times three eighteen
yes do you know what day we tell him if
you had a sick body too not now like
where everybody's just loving on
themselves no matter what they look like
yeah no you gotta I think everyone knows
I mean you should know that you gotta
everyone has room for improvement I want
to get tattoos sort of but I won't get
tattoos until I'm ripped that's my rule
so it's not even a question wait and
wait until you're 30. because but your
time you're 30 you're in a better place
mentally to know what you like and what
you're gonna like for a longer time when
you're 30 I will personally take you to
get a tattoo I'll pay for it and
everything
um I don't need your approval for that
you don't need my approval but I suggest
that I have I know a couple of things
more than you do about life and just you
sit and wait I'll get your face tatted
on my back you know you know just don't
get tattoos because you're going to make
bad decisions I know I'm positive of it
I've had some tattoo ideas that haven't
really changed
but radar Dave Independence here in
America doesn't make them good it's a
law 24th you know what language the
people who live in Idaho speak
no
what language do you think they speak
like what do they sound like they speak
I never heard them
do you know what century we're in
yes what country is Mount Rushmore in
it's hot
Russia
yes did he say what country yeah wow
that's crazy at least she's yeah at
least she's pretty you're gonna need
you're gonna need to use those looks
okay yo how many dimes make up one
dollar
how many dimes yeah
yeah 25. we've got the board ape shorts
though how many states make up the
United States
yes how many cents are in one dollar
how many sessions are one dollar yeah
one five ten twenty Thirty hundred six
yes do you know what country you just
say 106. I don't even know what Matthew
was doing what did he do there like what
was that I don't know what that math was
oh yeah with the math yeah no we don't
know nobody knows this girl call me if
you get lost let's see so we gained our
independence from
Mexico
don't call her if you get lost
it seems nice enough but Canada she
knows the way to the nail salon you know
what these are the girls that hate
Andrew Tate and have pronouns in their
bio and they're the ones whose opinions
that we need to take religiously well
you don't know that about her this girl
trying to take a guess what most of
these people's stances are let's take a
wild guess I don't know yes do you know
what two countries border the U.S
uh
I'm gonna touch the US above us and
below us bro
um the wall the wall where's the wall
one of the things that I've learned a
lot about in the past couple years is
discipline get control of your head
control your mind and learn discipline
and so you stop talking yourself out of
things and so you know Tom Shea the Navy
SEAL who we work with I went through his
21 day challenge where he gave me some
tasks to do every day and part of the
challenge was to wake up every day
commit to doing it and every time I
started to talk myself out of it I would
have an excuse run through my head some
lame ass excuse and there are four main
excuses that he teaches people that are
that ruin lives that's why we're doing
the 21 Day Challenge again together
which Sunny is not excited about because
he's going to have Tom on his ass if you
guys actually would like to do that with
us go to the link in the description
because there's a discount code come and
do it because guaranteed in one area of
your life there's something you're not
doing because you talk yourself out of
it every day you can go to the top of
the description click the link and buy
it with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing it with you
guys we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool what country is
Hawaii and Hawaii is its own country why
do you keep showing me things is it just
because you like to see my heart break
over the just the just slow demise of
the country that I love yeah it's fun
it's sad it's not just angry it's yeah
sometimes it's angry and sometimes it's
sad what went on in these School in
these classrooms what went on in their
home when they before they went to
school after they got home from school
is there no adult guidance in these
people's lives so that they could learn
anything anything you don't have to know
everything you don't have to be a genius
but for the love of God they have no
idea about the world around them none at
least this kid's got a killer fit on
a kill or what a killer fit what is a
fit his outfit you know you were
complimenting The Outfits last time
it's not a country I didn't know what
country is it in
you got this you have to guess you got
this it's a country
um oh you know this [__] it's a nice
Spanish [__] yeah
um
South America
I don't know
yes do you know how many minutes make up
one hour
let's see
not even on like like racist [__] but
like black people like say that where
it's like I be or like my mouth I don't
know what is going on in those
classrooms and I'm not saying like
that's not even like that's like just
true like and it's not all black people
it's more like where you come from
because I know white people from like
those neighborhoods that talk like that
but it's just really interesting to me
like when did that start a lot of people
that's instead of saying I saw they say
I seen it makes me want to flip a table
and I really I hate being a snob but
again you don't have to use big words
just to have some basic grammar rules
down so funny I love when the townies
are like so I goes and then he goes
that's the funniest
my mouth I haven't been to school in a
minute I finished College you finished
College
the shows that college has nothing to do
with actual intelligence I highly doubt
that this person went to college and
graduated I'm just saying I know people
that are like actually like like stupid
like they're like you you listen to
ideas and you're like wow that is
genuinely really dumb like that I don't
know how that even came out of your
mouth and these are the people with like
straight A's most college graduates know
how many minutes are in an hour and they
know to say I am not IB but I'm telling
you like with like business and [__]
like the way I analyze it now is a
totally different mindset than anything
I was taught in school like it's like
it's literally like chess like what Tate
says like I have a goal in mind so if
it's like getting people into my Discord
or following my Instagram and then you
analyze all the different ways you can
do it and then you pick like what are
the best moves you can make to achieve
that goal and that's just not something
taught in college it's taught like
you're supposed to do exactly this fill
it out and if you're wrong you fail like
it's not you can choose different
options and like use your brain like
that's not even a thing in college or
high school you know what do you
understand what I'm saying or like if
you're starting an agency like there's
different ways you can go for getting
clients there's different ways you can
charge clients run the systems and it's
like you just have to analyze what's
best and then pick and optimize and
that's not something you're taught
something that just like you have to
practice and comes with smarts you know
what I'm saying some things you learn by
experience but I feel like they taught
us more effectively when I was a kid did
they I I do do you know what country
Hawaii is in
some [__]
maybe that's a guess
I think Hawaii is its own country
yeah do you know when we celebrate
America's Independence
July 1st
July what July 1st
yes do you know what year the US was
founded
1827.
yes who fought in the Civil War dumb God
as in like
Ryan
um what what is that even what does that
even mean shooting range or like
fighting like what like Jake Paul fury
like what like what are you talking
about like a boxing match that happened
guys crazy man do you understand what he
means no
of course not sure what it means
on the Army and uh
wait which means the first Civil War
second third
oh he's thinking of those you never know
so like I'm thinking of anything the
Civil War
yeah because he said the third and
there's not even a third world war so I
don't know what he's
gonna get technical
I guess it was the Iraq U.S against Iraq
I am so sad how is that possible I don't
know where these people grew up what I
grew up in New York City and they taught
us history all of it they'll say that
like we were never taught history that
like I didn't learn about slavery and I
didn't learn about the Civil War and I
didn't learn about yeah you did Nazis
yeah I learned about all of it was it
weird learning about Nazis when you were
growing up because it like wasn't that
long ago yeah it was because I lived in
a my neighborhood was half Jewish and
there were some people in my
neighborhood who had been in camps oh
yeah like like the adults yeah yeah yeah
like oh they were older uh the people
that I knew but yeah they're all
definitely adults and older and a lot of
them were children also of people who
had been in camps so so it really was a
very personal to the neighborhood you
know story and I'm sure there are a lot
of neighborhoods that you know that
share that so World War II to you what
is that to me because that's like 30
years is that like the the Vietnam War
to me I'm difference wise no is it weird
for you that I was born after 9 11 like
that's a crazy thought that didn't live
through that [__] yeah it's it when I
think about the fact that you didn't
live through that I wonder it makes me
my mind go to I wonder what horrible
[__] you are going to live through do
you know what I mean yeah
so yeah so it's like yeah it's like 40
years almost since you were born 85
9505. oh yeah my phone's tripping who's
dumb now you can look up my birthday
right here yeah so it was like the
Vietnam War to you this [__] is so funny
to me
they added me here
he frequently his mom frequently appears
in his content wait I have to stop but
we'll go to the top look stop I'm trying
yeah birthplace is not correct but I I
said that oh okay I didn't I could have
put San Francisco but like uh yeah
Boston is you were just born there and
then we scurried you out of there as
fast as we could I'm the 8 000th most
firm famous person in the world
apparently to this [__] times three
why are you doing this for me
why the Raptor go through it no around
around what is that yes
but some of these people pretend to be
dumb because they think it's Charming or
cute I can't imagine that this grown man
doesn't know what seven times three is
it's it's not even fathomable to me is
he just trying to be cute is he cute to
be dumb is it popular to be dumb these
days is that what like what what what
goes on in young people's heads can you
enlighten me not much I can tell you
that
um
you put this like shrug and like oh
what's three times three times three
three times three screaming times three
three six nine nine if you were born 10
years ago how old would you be today no
man
13.
10 years ago so if you were born
in 2012. how old would you be 13.
yes how many days make up one year do
you think her friend realized that that
chick's like yes a complete Bozo I think
they're friends no I don't know there
wasn't too many thoughts I I just can't
help to think again that was another one
where I think the girl just thought she
was being funny holy [__] because the
friend was laughing how many days
31.
yes in one year and one year oh no
okay he thought he said a month uh oh
wait a day make up one year
you got it you got it around how many
like the whole year right yeah
like
half the year
so when I was in kindergarten we learned
the days of the week we learned the
months we learned the seasons you know I
remember I didn't know the months till I
was older I was like because they I
don't know what they were teaching you
when you were little that I could be a
girl and that I I was foolish enough to
trust that you were going to come out
having some basic knowledge well I
didn't come out with basic knowledge
we learned all the capitals of all the
states like that [__] does not matter it
does though it teaches you to how to
memorize things it teaches you about the
world around you it it really does it
and you take that you learn about a
state you learn about the capital of the
state you learn about the you know the
famous you know people from that [__]
was so boring well if you had a teacher
that made it boring there's like amazing
stories in every state and they could
have made it interesting yeah they did
not because they spent so much time
worrying about it it's got me like
20 years
yes nice that was genius all right thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe follow me on Instagram
at sunnyfaz growing out the mustache
coming in nice me too it's coming in
nice I'll see you later
[Music]